ever see news that makes you just go
yeah that was today for me if you
haven't heard by now Warner Brothers has
announced who is going to play Batman in
Man of Steel 2 if you don't remember it
was announced at Comic Con Batman is
going to be in the next Man of Steel
movie going head-to-head against
Superman so more or less this is the
single most important casting moment
that Warner Brothers is going to make
within the next few years and who do
they have to bring Batman The Dark
Knight back to the big screen to go
head-to-head against Superman Ben
Affleck of course I know right exactly
it'll be clear this isn't gonna be a
rant video it's not like when Megan Fox
was announced to be April O'Neill and I
just went apeshit on camera it's not
gonna be like that it's really I'm on
Affleck side I want him to succeed in
this I'm just saying I don't see it
Batman sir do you see it I'm just saying
Batman has layers to him you know he's
he's this guy he's damaged he's a
businessman he puts up a good facade but
that's all it is it's a facade deep down
inside he is this angry dude that he
unleashes as the Batman the Batman is
really who he is
nice Bruce Wayne it's all [ __ ]
there's complexity there and I'm not
saying Affleck isn't a complex person I
imagine he is but I haven't seen him do
anything that makes me think oh yeah
he's perfect as Batman and granted I
know the natural argument is when Heath
Ledger was cast as his Joker people were
like brokeback Joker and it's true there
were naysayers out there but Ledger you
could tell he hadn't done everything he
had to offer he still had that untapped
potential that he hadn't unleashed on to
the big screen so you're like I want to
see what he does with this with Affleck
I feel like I've seen everything he has
to bring and nowhere in there to never
think to myself is that granteth the
dude looks like he should be a superhero
you know he's got the chance or like I I
would imagine he should be put on screen
as some superhero but I someone did that
which is also risky because when he's on
screen as Batman people are gonna see
daredevil the studio might see something
I don't because you know that they were
like alright we're gonna cast Ben
Affleck as Batman and there's gonna be
some fan backlash comic-book fans are
passionate and I don't think a lot of
them will be like Oh totally Ben Affleck
so apparently they believe that the next
two years of backlash they're going to
get is worth having Ben Affleck in the
movie as Batman that being said at a
point someone truly believed Nicolas
Cage would be a great Superman and I'm
just I'm glad that didn't happen
case in point Studios don't always get
it right you want
comparison I see the situation like this
remember when they were talking about
casting Mark Wahlberg as Nathan Drake in
an uncharted movie nothing against Mark
Wahlberg I think the guy is a fine actor
I just don't think he's Nathan Drake
same thing here I have nothing against
Ben Affleck [ __ ] The Dude's a great
director and in the movies he directs
he's really good also I just don't see
him as Batman Bruce Wayne sure like the
Bruce Wayne businessman facade that
Bruce Wayne purposely puts up so people
don't know he's Batman perfect for that
but I don't think I'll see this guy and
be like nah that's all [ __ ] deep
down he is damaged he's the Batman I'd I
just don't see that Batman's a hard
character to cast because you need
someone who totally fits as Bruce Wayne
and can pull off Batman I would have
imagined someone with Michael Fassbender
looks and Karl Urban's gruffness Karl
Urban probably be a good Batman I don't
know about Bruce Wayne could be like on
that and be like I'm Bruce Wayne be like
are you sure you're not Batman I mean
I've seen a flick in other movies where
he's played an angry character or a
darker character but it still feels like
Ben Affleck playing those things he's up
on a rooftop talking like Batman he's
not it's Ben Affleck with a cape that's
just how I'm gonna see it I feel like
I'm not alone out there I think a lot of
people are gonna see it like that I just
see things like this as a gambling game
the game was alright is Ben Affleck
going to make a great Batman or not I
would not put my chips on going to make
a great Batman this is an opportunity
for him he has an opportunity to show
all the fanboy naysayers out there what
he's got you can kill it as Batman be
like boom don't think I've shown you
everything never doubt the athlete I'd
be awesome actually I feel like I what
do I know now this is a thought that
just crossed my mind and bear with me on
this hair what if his Batman suit is a
new Batman suit where you know the
mouthpiece where you can see that human
mouth and Batman's outfit but if that's
completely solid like you don't see his
face at all in which case Ben Affleck
sakteng and him being cast in this movie
really he's there to be Bruce Wayne when
he's Batman you don't see him at all so
you're not gonna see Ben Affleck at that
point you can have like Kane Hodder or
Kevin Nash super shredder just running
around in a Batman suit you never know
now keep in mind that's not plan a for
me I'd like to see an actor who can
encompass both Bruce Wayne and Batman I
like the fact that you can see Batman's
mouth so you can be like now that's
still the same guy but in a world where
I can't see Ben Affleck being Batman but
I can see him being Bruce Wayne I just
think a suit like that would make more
sense when you're casting Ben Affleck as
Batman again thought that just crossed
my mind I don't know what they're gonna
do all I know is if you can see his
mouth mmm barso Ben Affleck playing
Batman
in Man of Steel - what do you think of
it if you don't like it who would you
have cast is Batman whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more